you dragged our reputation through the
mud
you're acting out a personal grudge
against dad there's a foundational
sickness within our father and his
company or do you not actually give a
[ __ ] and it's all just ego jeremy i sat
down on my couch to start season three
in the screeners we got and i was like
kendall unleashed let's go
so excited
um congratulations on your emmy i so
admire the links you go to to bring a
character to life i was reading
that on the set of the big short you
actually looked at pictures of plane
crashes to like enter a certain mindset
so i wanted to know what do you look at
when you're playing kendall and like
what brings you to kendall land you know
music is a big part of it i listen to a
lot of music on set you know there's a
playlist for kendall jesse and i sort of
usually reference books we've we
reference a lot of you know each season
there have been certain pieces of
literature that like
become a touchstone for the season in
season two it was crime and punishment
and in season three it was f scott
fitzgerald's book the crack up i think
kendall feels very free at the start of
this season like he's finally
rested himself free from his father's
like death grip
and
he's emancipated himself and he also
has been given the
the the sort of clarity and the vision
and the knowledge of what he has to do
and which is to sort of be a savior for
the company and for the culture and
and he sees himself as that's been sort
of almost divinely appointed
and there's this element of like
kind of a manic
flight to what's going on one thing i
love about kendall and your performance
is that he wears his inner hurt child on
his sleeve and i very much relate to
that and i wanted to ask you is that
really uncomfortable to play to be that
vulnerable or is it actually really
freeing to like let go of those feelings
creatively it feels like a tremendous
burden to be called on to to go through
those things in your work but that's the
deal and
that's sort of what's being asked of
of me here and
but you never know if if those things
you know emotion and the unconscious
they're very
mercurial things like
you have no control over
them and as an actor you have no control
over whether
they'll show up on the day
it is just like a game and you're very
invested in it and committed to it
utterly but it only exists within the
container of what you're doing and in a
way in and through the words the writing
do you go through the writing and do
anything to it to make it more kindle i
don't know if i do need to make it more
kindle but i do a lot of work on the
script yeah what are some things is
there anything that you could share
jesse is incredibly permissive and
collaborative and you know it's less
about making it more kindle than making
it
track for me as the actor
so that it feels consistent and it feels
aligned with what my instincts are i
feel like i am him and i understand
what he would want and say and do and
feel in in any given moment can you give
us an example of like something that
we've seen that you've sort of like
tweaked and you're like no i feel like
this is more kendall i just find this
stuff so fascinating
it's more about sometimes
sometimes there are things
in where i don't feel like i have what i
need to get to where it needs to get me
to you know for example
at the end of season two
when i'm on the boat with my dad
the script had always existed in a way
that he said you're not a killer and
that was meant to be sort of the trigger
and the catalyst for for what i then
went on to do
and i felt very strongly that
that that wasn't enough and that that
and that he had my father has
essentially said that to me before he
said that to me in the pilot episode
it's not a big dick competition that
didn't feel like enough of a of a of a
sort of
uh of a firing pin and we talked a lot
about
why and what it could be and
and then and then one night jesse came
in with a rewrite
where my father referenced the boy in
england which didn't used to be in the
scene
and said nrpi no real person involved
and by connecting what was happening
with the cruz scandal and he had denied
ever using that phrase so now he uses
that phrase
revealing that
he's a liar
but he uses it in such a
monstrous way in a way that is like what
kind of person
could say that no real person involved
that's an example not of me saying
that wasn't my idea that was just an
example of feeling of of wondering
of saying i feel like i need a string a
springboard here
and what might that be
so when i read that
it was just amazing i mean i i'm
astonished by jesse armstrong as a
writer and and and that allowed the
character to see in his father something
like that he hadn't really seen before
wow jeremy that's so powerful thank you
for sharing that with me i love that um
what was shooting that rap scene like
the most cringy thing ever and do people
ask you to do that all the time or was
it people asked me to do it it wasn't
cringy at all i mean it was like you
know
i
i think
i love that everyone cringed for me but
you know i think kendall i think i it
felt quite sincere and maybe that's why
everyone cringes but i think uh uh it
was a it was a it was a gift that he
gave to his dad you know as an actor
you're always like you will kind of want
to walk the plank because that's where
that's where you grow
so that was just an example of
one of many
planks that
they give me to walk out on there he is
the little man who started this big war
right now i'm the real you sure and i'm
the real you you sound deranged
sarah congratulations on the show and
season three it is so good when i watch
it i feel like i'm watching a reality
show the way you guys step on each
other's dialogue and i always wondered
is that a direction you're given or is
that the way it's written in the script
uh both it it it it definitely is
encouraged the looseness and the uh over
the you know moving throughout each
other over conversations and dialogue
and and that's just natural that's like
that's life that's how we talk we we
talk in in
in shortened and and hijacked sentences
and then over the top of people and um i
think i love that because it just feels
as you said like a reality tv show in
some ways but it's like this high drama
amazing dialogue at the same time and
the way we shoot it with the zoom pops
and like very shaky or you know very
sort of there's a lot of movement in the
camera
it feels again like reality
right exactly and shiv is you know she's
just one of my favorite characters i
wanted to dive deep with you on how you
really built her what was the first
thing you did when you found out you got
the role as far as prep goes
oh i mean
i'm no billionaire and i have not come
from money so
the first thing i did was start to like
watch things like the queen of uh
versailles the um the lauren greenfield
documentary and and watch like uh the
there's a
the documentary that the johnson johnson
air made uh born rich i think and and
watched films about you know what it is
to grow up with with money and privilege
in this in this way um actually there
was a book also generation wealth which
was lauren greenfield as well that i
found enormously useful just to just
like have a visual reference to like
look at what money is in america it's
not the book isn't about um billionaires
it's just about what money is in america
and um over you know the generations and
yeah i
that kind of thing i found really useful
the accent that you have for her is so
good did you were you inspired by anyone
specifically i worked with a dialect
coach um who
who helped me what what my main aim
really was to was to make my own voice
really be able to sit in my own voice
and then just tweak it a little bit to
make it sound american um i think
previously when i was doing an american
accent uh i felt like i was putting on
an accent it may not have sounded like
that but i felt like i was
putting something on and i knew that for
this one i wanted it to really sit in me
sit in my voice and sit sit closer to
my natural speaking voice so that like
improvising and and just being her on a
day-to-day basis was was much easier
it's such a good voice i love the voice
i also love shiv's stonewall like
her physicality and i wondered you know
where did you pull that from
oh
stonewall
i think that's also come from like
me as an actor going sarah going i don't
know what to do right now i'll be very
still
and there's something that
you know that shiv does where she just
like there's something powerful about
not talking and there's something more
powerful about uh listening and and
being uh the observer in the room and
and being judicious when she talks uh
and i like that about about her mind you
there's also like the part of shiv that
is um that acts before she thinks and
says things of like you know the dinner
table like just tells me um and you're
like no stop what are you doing
but um
yeah
i love when shiv and logan are together
to your scenes with brian cox who in the
end
which of the roy children do you think
ends up with the big job
oh like you as sarah
do any i mean do any of them i don't
know like do any of them deserve it
probably not uh does
logan think will logan ever give it to
us
you know we'd have to like
we'd have to earn it and i don't know
whether we'd be able to earn it in a way
that logan would be satisfied to give it
to us in any of us so
i really it's a it's a great question
because it's the question that in a way
drives the show but it's a question that
i think is unanswerable as well which is
you know why the show is uh so addictive
in ways i think
the fbi is downstairs
yeah these are the ones who don't off
can we ask them to come back tomorrow
you know what's so funny you put those
glasses on just now because i wondered
if that was a part of jerry's character
always or if you wore you know glasses
that didn't have
but i don't need them for this so i just
had them on for now um yeah i wear
glasses but it's definitely
cherry
ah
costume as well did you add that to
jerry
yeah
i love that i always wondered you know
what does jerry really think about the
roy family like what's her stance on
everybody
um i think she admires logan a lot uh
sometimes begrudgingly because i think
he's a pain in the ass but
and i think she thinks the others are
idiots like destructive idiots you know
and that
well kind of endeared himself somehow um
not as a sexual partner but just as a
like in some
ineffable way just gotten under skin a
bit like she's
in spite of herself become a bit
attached to him that's my take yeah i
love that i love that you confirmed that
too because i was like jerry's gotta
think she's like smarter than all of
these people
jay how do you think jerry's story arc
has evolved can you explain that and is
it something that you had to build on or
did you know from the very beginning
what her arc was going to be
you know when i started
it was just a recurring role she was one
of many suits and then i was really only
hired to be in the first
episode two through
six of season one and i sort of willed
myself to be written into every episode
i was just
acting you know just recurring character
at that point and then i just feel like
i um as i say i just feel like i willed
myself into existence sort of i'm
luckily enough though that jesse and the
other writers just responded to that
and that kieran responded you know that
we kind of
the chemistry was just right and and it
all kind of unfolded in a good way it's
so cool to hear you say that because i
mean obviously the best part of this
show is that psychosexual chemistry that
you have with kieran and i was reading
you know that you and karen actually
you know flirted in season one and that
the writers picked up on that and then
wrote it into the show and that's so
cool that you had this instinct for
jerry is there anything else maybe in
your willing and or in that instinct for
jerry that you've done that the writers
have picked up on that maybe we wouldn't
know about
well i think when i auditioned you know
um jerry was originally written to be a
man
and it you know so those first scenes
some of the lines turned out to be show
up in a frank scene later some of them
stayed jerry lines but um i didn't have
the scripts i just had these isolated
scenes i did wasn't really sure what the
context was
but i thought they were funny you know i
kind of got the gist
but you know in both cases one scene was
with kendall i think
and one was with roman or one was with
both of them and one was with roman
something like that
and uh
you know they would say these really
coarse things to jerry the guy
the way they all talk to each other you
know the way
frank and carl and they all talk to each
other in a disgusting way but now it was
a woman
and so i just um i i
wasn't defending i wasn't
like thrown by it my character wasn't
thrown by it but i just like ugh you
know like i was just grimacing over
everything that became part of the
character right away like that sort of
eye-rolling and like
long-suffering quality that that
jerry is always like
at the horrible things they say you know
right it's
kind of part of the running story about
jerry
she has such a cool balance of being
that conduit for the audience like being
that wincy eye rolly character but also
like being very much in the show as like
one of those strong characters my
favorite thing about jerry that jay you
just bring to life so well she's so
unsentimental she's so private um she
gives so much by giving so little i
wanted to ask you specifically is that
is it more challenging to play a
character
that is private you know is it easier to
pay to play a character that's an open
book i think in this case it is
difficult but it's fun like i i like
that she
like when we do find anything out about
jerry it's just like little pieces that
sort of surprise you like
like when i'm taking pictures of my name
on the television screen for my
daughters but just a little bitty times
when you're like oh she's a mother you
know like she that was a motherly move
you know like so i think it's it's
definitely fun
but it's hard because you're like you
don't really know you have to make it up
for yourself
um what your objective is what's your
intention behind something you're doing
how she feels about it it's it's sort of
like i just have to kind of
intuit that because i don't have facts
about her
um agenda or her backstory you know it's
great and to interpretation which of the
roy children do you think ends up with
the big job at the end
i'm not sure a roy child is going to end
up with a big job
um
i'm not sure who will be
i think from jerry's point of view i
think
at this point in the story she thinks it
could be roman
with her tutelage i think she i think
he's looking more and more like a young
logan in a way like kind of a
you know a firebrand and a
you know a kind of a
maverick
you know
and
so i think and i think that
shiv is um sort of a hot head and
kendall seems like a doomed character at
least to jerry like i think
like he he was on paper the good choice
and i just think he's
a tragic character you know
um
so it seems like roman is maybe the one
that when he matures like a fine wine he
might be one day
but that's at the beginning of season
three i i make no predictions about by
the end of that time
and you know i mean
sometimes it's not at all who you think
it is sometimes it's like
a cousin
or
or an employee
you know ooh
or something over someone who takes over
the company you know so there's a
million ways it could spin out no one
knows i mean jesse must let's have some
ideas
roman is a knucklehead shiv is a fake
and kenny is screwy i've seen more than
any of them so you've come a long way
since cameron fry i was hoping that you
could sort of compare and contrast
connor and cameron because i feel like
they both take themselves very seriously
yeah yeah yeah uh cameron's wrapped uh a
lot more tighter than
uh and connor connor's let some things
go over the years maybe he was maybe he
was just as you know
neurotic as uh
cameron was way back when
um somebody said that the other day and
it hadn't really occurred to me as like
oh
uh son of an abusive cold and distant
father and i was like oh yeah
yeah i guess that's my niche
yeah
so interesting you know connor is he
he's the oldest of the trust fund babies
so i'm curious what is his perspective
on his role in the family
well i mean uh truthfully i mean he sort
of got estranged from his dad back when
the divorce happened
when connor was probably about eight
years old and
there was a period of time where i
actually didn't see my dad for a few
years and i was living with my mother
who we found out was
had some mental challenges and some
abuse substance problems and so forth
and um
out of institutions so he was
alternately living with a very sick
woman or he was in boarding school
and um
so i think for many years he's basically
been uh knocking on logan's window from
time to time just like let me in
let me back in yeah and you know conor
has like he has like this empathy gene
that the other siblings sort of don't
have
that's because they're all rotten
yeah exactly
sarah they're just terrible
so where you know did you write
something in his backstory you know is
that
is that why he's why is he you know sort
of warm as opposed to the other sibling
i just think um
he
he's uh he's a little damaged you know
he's he's probably got adhd and he's got
delusional disorder and um
for whatever reason he just doesn't uh
at least we haven't seen it yet that
killer instinct that they all seem to
have i can tell you at some point conor
does realize that the only way to get
ahead in this family is to play dirty
that's a really big tease going into
season three and that's exciting was
that fun to tap into that part of conor
because you haven't been able to do that
yet yeah i haven't said too much really
in the story so far is like i say some
inane thing at a family gathering and
i'm told to shut up and then you know i
move on uh so i've had more to do and
i've had more
one-on-one scenes with my sister and
with my father and there's more going on
right what's so great about this show
and what i'm gathering from talking to
the cast is that it's it's really the
words and that you are given so much to
work with um aside from all that stuff
is there anything ellen that you wanted
specifically to bring to conor that we
see on screen and maybe we didn't know
that it was i don't know if it's
something in his in his physicality or
in the way he dresses or does his hair
is there anything that you really wanted
to bring to the character kevin costner
had this look in jfk and it was kind of
like the giorgio armani uh uh style of
like 1963
with pleated pants and and waistcoats
and stuff and i was like
well you know it's he's kind of out of
time he's uh
you know connor's a little bit out of
time why why doesn't he bring back
pleated pants and and and you know
suits um so we'll see we'll see that's
an idea i had for just how he looked but
uh
i i mean i do think at some point uh
conor will show his teeth i think
i think he'll bite back at some point
oh i can't wait for that that just got
me so excited i love i love conor so
much because he just has this like
libertine lifestyle and i was like if i
was a if i was a member of the roy
family i'd probably be living on a ranch
as well
what is it like alan shooting these like
massive family scenes i i'd imagine
they're like 10 pages long on script
like can you just describe the energy
because you know you're there for them
and is it just like boom boom boom boom
like can you sort of paint the picture
for us on what it's like to be on set
for those it's very exciting we have a
fabulous props department when we did
the thing in uh season two at turn haven
when cherry jones played the the
matriarch of of the pierce family and we
went to their mansion you know like the
family compound we had this huge dinner
scene
right our prop department ever because
we did take after take after take after
take and every plate had to look the
same at the beginning of the scene and
they had it down
like that so i mean we're working with
the top-notch
you know crew and um
it's just you have to stay in it you
just have to stay in it because you
never really know when the camera is
going to be on you
uh especially with mark mylod well most
of them i mean we're we're shooting i
used to call it vomit vision except we
we don't move the cameras that fast
anymore the only thing that they used to
do on um nypd blue where they do whip
pans you know and you know but we do
some of that you know and so you just
have to you just have to stay in the
scene you can't check out you can't be
like oh this is on this is on brian or
this is on uh jeremy it's just just know
you're going to be in it somehow and you
just have to stay in and so it's uh it's
real ensemble work
you know and you have to you have to
listen and uh you just have to stay
present but it's uh it's a lot of fun a
lot of energy a lot of terrific actors i
mean besides our regulars you know we we
get guest stars that are phenomenal it
makes you want to do your best work
right right it's just it's like
infectious is any information ever
withheld from you like when you guys are
shooting these scenes like does
something sort of surprising happen that
you guys improvise with or is it really
just like all on paper
we do it as written and then they always
come up with alternate lines that are
always brilliant you know because they
can't help themselves they they just
kept they keep writing and then we
always do a free one
we call it free one at the end which is
just improv and sometimes it just it's
like you know not it's crap but
sometimes
you get something you get like little
pieces of gold i just wanted to know
which of the roy children do you think
ends up with a big job at the end none
of them
i don't i mean i was very impressed by
roman last season because who would have
thought that the knucklehead would
actually turn out to be an astute
businessman because he he told his
father he told logan at the end of the
the season he said that thing that that
that offer that they pitched it was you
know it was all horseshit it was just
like a coke fueled fantasy or whatever
he was right you know so uh for a while
i thought
roman and jerry you know that the
two-headed monster they could do it but
now
maybe just jerry
i hear you tried to kill dad again fatty
do you have a fetish for nearly killing
dad
like just the tip but for killing dad
karen how are you
swell
you know what people say uh
you know get your mind out of the gutter
i feel like that's literally where roman
lives i and i have yet to find a
character on television with like just
the greatest lines ever do you have a
favorite do you have a favorite line
that roman has set
no it's all so
juicy and
bubbly and wonderful
um i wish i had an answer to that
sometimes because it also leaves me so
fast like
sometimes go home and really love
something that we did and for a couple
of days i'll think about it like man
that was fun and then it's gone and i i
can remember the idea of it
like there was something about like
yelling something at a a waystar
employee about how jerry's going on a
date with a man named laurie
and i i can't remember how it goes
anymore but i loved it at the time it
was so much fun
why did you love that in particular so
much oh because it was fun to like
play the the jealousy which i think was
a really
honest sort of choice on
the writers like i'm reading it and like
reading jerry saying she's going on a
date and i immediately
like as i'm reading i'm like no that's
[ __ ] like
don't don't go on that date that's mine
that's my date
like and then seeing that like okay good
they wrote that they wrote that as well
they agree
romans shouldn't stop at that
so that's one
you know roman so well my favorite line
in particular that i actually have used
in real life later on is i'm dumb but
i'm smart
like
okay
i've used that quite a bit yeah i'm done
but i'm smart it makes sense yeah you
still got your favorite lines from the
show is not mine it's just uh and it's
this simple tom it was
buckle up
buckle up heads is
just wonderful
also there's one another one that isn't
mine terry walters is like i didn't want
to make a big bolus of governs
such a throwaway line of person i've
used it a lot
because like in life i've used a lot
it's like well no like i just want to do
this because i don't want to make like a
big bolus of governs of it you know
it turns out it's not really an
expression he just sort of jesse just
sort of made it up but he thought about
it
and then found out it wasn't
i was talking to alan and he was saying
that you know you guys do the takes and
that sometimes you do versions where you
guys just improvise i was wondering were
there any scenes with roman and jerry
where you guys improvised and there was
something that ended up on the cutting
room floor that you could maybe share
with us that didn't make it in the show
yeah like especially in the first season
like stuff that didn't make it like we
were just always
flirting with each other like very
inappropriately and the
the one i guess that they
had seen um at the in the last episode
of the first season
uh i was chatting with jerry at the bar
and then you know the cameras kept
rolling so i said something like can i
borrow your tortoise because i remember
like at the beginning of the season her
like husband had a tortoise i was like
can i borrow your tortoise for a weekend
and she goes okay yeah well i mean she
goes yeah okay fine good and i started
walking past and i was like i'm gonna
out of your tortoise
it's like rolled her eyes and then i
like walked past and i looked at her
butt and i kept walking then she turned
and looked at my butt and neither of us
knew that the other did that and i guess
they saw that they were like oh that's
fun let's try to explore that and i
think they've been kind of
in the second season started writing a
little bit towards just to see what it
looks like and which is a lot of fun
yeah that's so cool to be able to do
that and then for the writers to just
like take it and run with it is there
anything else that you wanted to
personally
bring to romulus that wasn't maybe in
the writing i know so much of it is in
the writing but
that was one idea that was like the main
one i really wanted for the first season
was like i really hope that there's
something
it couldn't be on the nose but something
pseudo
romantic going on with roman and jerry
was like a real hope of mine and the
fact that they start to explore that was
uh amazing for me yeah and there was oh
there was another one where i sort of
had this
idea
which ended up being kind of similar to
what they did which was like roman going
into like um the training like
um business
training or whether whatever he goes
away to like you know they make fun of
him for it
but like it's funny because i had an
idea of he should do something like that
uh and then they did it so anytime i
feel you know i don't know i'm just i'm
i'm on board for the ride but sometimes
i have these
these thoughts that i couldn't share
with you now so it's not really worth
even wasting time but i have some like
once i like
said it once to jesse at the end of the
second season i threw this one idea and
he was like
but i haven't seen it yet
uh and i don't want to push it i want to
see
i want to see if it happens
okay well what is like your favorite
moment that you've that you've had
playing romulus because he has so many
good ones that we've seen so far not not
in season three
i think it was we were all about to go
to the pierces
uh it was like logan had us all gather
in his living room to talk about uh like
strategy and when we go meet the
pierce's um and there was something
about like
clothing like what clothes you should
wear and there were different alts so
like it's
fun to make people break and laugh too
there's some people that are pretty hard
to break but i remember making alan
laugh which was kind of a feat because
he never breaks because i said yeah like
barring clothing like because i had all
the results and then they started
[ __ ] around i said boring clothing
yeah i was thinking of wearing like a
a crotchless ghee with like a fluffy
merkin
and for whatever reason because i know
allen's sense of humor merkin is just a
good buzzword to make him laugh so
seeing him break he actually put his
head in a pillow and which ruined the
take
which was great
some people are some people break really
easy mcfadden
he's an easy breaker
always so satisfying sometimes he'll
just go
and sometimes it's nothing like you know
somebody walking the trip a little bit
as they walk and he's about to he's
about to blow the tank in the end which
of the roy children you think gets the
big job
roman definitely
i think that i'm i think
he uh
i think he's the most like his father
and i think uh he could actually run the
business the way logan would and his
other kids wouldn't do that logan says
we have to take these
cyanide pills
it's a mint you doofus i'm sure you've
been asked this before about how hard is
it for you
to keep a straight face when you're
doing those scenes with shiv or cousin
greg or is it just like no it's very
hard
it's very hard because they're so funny
and and sarah and nick is so brilliant
and um so yeah sometimes we just lose it
but yeah yeah the crew are very patient
with
us your older brother sort of
energy towards cousin greg is so
you just like feel it you know when
you're watching the show i always
wondered do you and and nicholas braun
who plays cousin greg do you guys do
anything offset to sort of build on that
or do you do anything outside to build
on that not to build it we just hang out
you know we we hang out and now and
again and uh
no but it's all there on the right i
mean it's all there in the writing and
you sort of develop
you develop rhythms and chemistry
together when as you
you know the more you act together you
do this so it just comes naturally and
so you sort of when it when it when
you're in the right area it sort of
feels good and you know
what is it like when you guys do these
10-page scenes and then it's like done
like is it just like yeah like we nailed
that like because they are so long and
they're so good and they feel so real
you take a deep breath and you sort of
jump in and then
it's sort of quite gladiatorial you know
you're sort of the the adrenaline
because you have to it's a different
sort of concentration than doing little
nuggets of moments you know which we do
as well but
it's just really exciting and because
the actors
the actors are so brilliant
that you're sort of fascinated with what
i don't know kieran's about to do or
brian or sarah
you know so you're the level of
concentration is different somehow i
always wondered too like the sets are
just so lavish it's almost like you're
just watching it's like the crown you
know like what is it like
leaving that set and you know sort of
going back into your real life and then
coming back into it and how much does it
like how much does the set lend itself
to putting you in into the mindset of
tom
entirely lends itself i mean there's no
imagination required because we're on a
yacht or you know they built a huge they
built like the senate hearings room we
were in one of the chambers and so there
isn't
even if we're in the studio the the sets
are so
so
superbly done that it's not a leap of
the imagination you know to think that
you're there i really do enjoy when the
show dips into shiv and tom's world
because there
there is like
some sort of odd warmness to them
along a little i mean
i think they have a laugh i think they
sort of they can
bounce off each other i just think
fundamentally
i don't know i mean he's annoying and
she's
so blocked you know
she's so
you know unable to to sort of
be loved in a way you know
um
so it's an it's a really interesting
relationship
a lot of people i know have asked you
this
you know why
why are tom and shift together
and i know it's sort of like
up into interpretation but there is
really a lot of love there but i
wondered matthew like do you think tom
and shiv make it in the end do you think
they last
i don't know
don't know when
yeah i don't know i mean i genuinely
don't know
who who out of the roy children do you
think ends up with the big job in the
end
uh maybe it's not maybe it's none of
them maybe it's
it's greg or
frank i don't know i really don't know
do you have because season three
starts right off where season two ended
like there's no time in between can you
sort of let us know where we find your
character tom right now in this moment
uh the beginning of season three
beginning of season three it's kind of
reeling from
they had a he and shiv had a
conversation on the beach in
croatia and he sort of said i don't you
know i'm not sure i'm happy with you you
know and
that's the closest he's got to sort of
saying i you know maybe this is not
maybe we're not gonna last and so
they're reeling from that a bit and then
shiv and tom have not had time to sort
of discuss or process this this thing
this bump in their marriage and uh and
they're suddenly in crisis mode the
whole company's in crisis mode because
of kendall's
actions and so
yeah he's like he's on quicksand all the
time and that's sort of you know it's
very yeah it's very bumpy at the
beginning of season three that's what's
so fun to watch about tom though it does
feel like he's just like on quicksand
all the time did you have to eat that
chicken like a bunch of times what was
it like shooting that scene with brian
it was great that was like we did like
four or five tanks maybe
i took a really big bite at the
beginning and he laughed and i went and
i was so i
i ate too much and i had too much in my
mouth i couldn't speak
brian cracked up and he never does so i
was gone i was just gone sorry just
a chicken bits of chicken leg after that
logan is very interested what you're up
to you
when animals corpse and hide
strong wow nice and strong strong one
strong for a man i so enjoyed the song
you put out last year and since you put
it out it made me want to ask you do you
think
cousin greg will have a music moment in
the show to rival kendall's rap
unfortunately i don't think greg is very
musical
i don't think he has rhythm
uh something i thought about
in season one when he's at the wedding i
was like how does greg dance
um
and i think he doesn't dance to the beat
properly
so
so yeah i think greg won't have a
musical moment unfortunately uh unless
it's more dancing
and and confirming you haven't written a
cousin greg rap
to rival kendall's because you're so
good at writing
no i think greg might have like approved
uh some of kendall's rap like jeremy and
i thought like kendall probably came
over and was like this is what i'm
thinking about
and there was one point where he was
like jeremy was like maybe maybe greg
should like come up on stage because he
knows the chorus because
because i would have shared it with you
but
um so anyway i think they're tight like
that
but
greg didn't write any any of those
lyrics i don't think
yeah well that sucks we won't get to see
that because i feel like you're you
would have like been able to put a good
like rap together to rival kendall's but
cousin greg like he's way smarter than i
think he lets on to be even though his
dance moves might not be great
what do you think his odds are of taking
over away star
i i believe that he's capable
um
because he's
certainly ambitious
uh he's learning some of the skills he's
learning how to like be
a dick um a bit you know i think he's
like learning how to be kind of like the
required [ __ ] that they all are i
think he's capable you know he's not as
cold as they are but um
but maybe he's like part of the good
version of waystar uh
something i think he really wants to be
a billionaire where do you think he gets
like that ambition from i find that
people with huge ambition come
from
a childhood where they
were like stifled or or they came from
like
a version of poverty and not that greg
came from poverty but i think
uh his grandpa ewan like rationed money
out to him and his mom and apparently
greg's uh dad
left
them
uh apparently for for another man
if i don't know if you remember that
when he's called greg the egg it's like
okay um
so yeah so i think it comes out of that
like you want what you didn't have when
you grew up
and and so um
he's like oh i get a chance to be on the
side where they like actually spend the
money and they don't just hold it in a
bank account like ewan does
uh
i think there's something there and i
think there's a weird like he's got a
confidence in himself but it comes out
in weird ways and
you know he doesn't talk to talk like
they do he doesn't know how to like be a
deal maker but i think he really
believes in himself at the same time
i think you do such a good job too of of
balancing cousin greg's confidence and
nervousness and i was wondering how do
you strike that balance
it's a very cool thing you know to be
like so nervous to be like this nervous
puppy and want to please everyone but
also have ambition and then when you say
things and are sure of them have that
like conviction you know so it's like
how do you find that bounce between
confidence and nervousness
well i don't think
anyone would
love him if he's only nervous
like he would be annoying like why why
is he around like i have to justify why
he's kept around
these are super important
rooms that he's in
and um in season three he's included in
even
smaller circles of people um
so i believe he has to have
an intelligence and a confidence that
underlies all of the
the discomfort and sort of the failure
of trying um otherwise if he's just
nervous and bad at it then he's gone
yeah so he has no dancers so yeah danny
there's no dance moves
yeah the best i mean i want to go back
to something you just said too because
he's like the heart of the show he's not
corrupted like the other roys are
do you think we are going to see that
change as this series goes on
yeah
yeah i do i i think he
slips a bit deeper slowly slips into the
dark side
but you know it's not so easy like he is
a decent good person
in his core
so it's more just like he has to take
actions
in order to stay in this circle that
aren't
good
so yeah yeah i
i i'm not going to say he goes full you
know full dark but i think
these people are affecting him the way
that they are um
affects him
yeah after talking to you and alan i'm
i'm so stoked for this season because it
seems like these sort of nice characters
like like connor and greg we're gonna
see like different sides to them which
is so exciting um but speaking of
different sides
cousin greg's nervousness is just it's
so fun to watch and after seeing the
surprise romance between jerry and roman
last season do you think we get to see
that nervousness from cousin greg and
his love life like do we get to see do
you think he falls in love or like does
he have a type or does he even know what
love is
i think he hasn't had a successful
relationship in his life
um i think he was a bit of a mama's boy
like it was you know only child lived
with his mom
she was like a
helicopter parent whatever you want to
call it and um
and so now that he's on his own and and
basically has no one to
give him any affection um ever in this
world i think he is seeking some romance
and um i don't know how much of the
season you've seen
but it but it is um
it is something that
he goes for
um oh
that's exciting
yeah yeah yeah i should yeah i shouldn't
say too much and i don't know if hbo
will even like me saying that much but
um but yeah i mean the first episode he
he flirts with a girl um
you have you seen you've seen the first
episode
yeah yeah first two okay
uh so he
yeah he's he's gonna go for that so he's
got he's he needs something that feels
good that's so exciting he needs some
real intimacy you know
right right yeah
a lot of them need a lot of a lot of
love i think what was it like you know
to sort of contrast that love and talk
about one of the craziest scenes i've
ever seen on tv was that water bottle
scene in the panic room of season two
what was it like shooting that like how
many takes did you have to deal with
that
it's one of those scenes that he and i
get
where you're like where it's like five
pages and and there's all these
different things happening
and
it was fun i i don't know i wanted to
get hit by water bottles uh
i wanted i wanted to get hit i wanted it
to hurt i wanted to be afraid of tom
um
i wanted it to be a really scary moment
for greg of seeing like who is this guy
like this guy is
this
like he's this explosive and scary and
sensitive and like
i was just trying to like move up in the
world you know like
which i thought he'd respect and then
and then it makes him explode at me
so there was like so much going on and
we just wanted to do justice to that
scene and um and i just told him let it
rip
give it to me
wow that must have hurt then
yeah there were some yeah there were
some painful ones um
it was also like i was like running into
a desk every time like there i was like
up against the desk my my leg was like
so banged up from all day just like
bashing into this trying to get away
from him um
so anyway it was just it was it was one
of the best days the panic room stuff
was really fun i'm better than you
you're corrupt
evil
don't talk about things you don't
understand
i know things about the world or i
wouldn't turn a book i know you've
played king lear and what i love about
king lear's story is you know he's this
king that has to
wants to retire and divvy up his land
among his three daughters and he's going
to give the biggest portion you know to
the daughter he loves the most and i
just you know there's so many
similarities between king lear and logan
so i wanted to know you know what
attracts you to these types of roles and
and what is the secret sauce when it
comes to balancing love and power
amongst your children it's not
what attracts me is it's what attracts
the other way around you know i i seem
to get attracted to those roles you know
uh
and i played so many of them that uh
i mean it's it it was so logical to play
logan roy after this to do a modern
version of these
similar themes and
it's kind of it's so weird but i was
talking about this earlier on it's a
very strange feeling because it's like
of course it's meant that that's what i
do i play these kind of characters i
played churchill i played goring i
played
uh
you know
ward abbott and the bourne films you
know
striker so i play these power people
and it's the sort of thing that just has
happened you know i mean i
do it and i get asked to do it and i
will do it and uh
it's great i enjoy it and of course
logan is the sort of pinnacle of them
you know i mean lear is in the theater
is pretty pinnacle but
in terms of the modern media uh logan is
the pinnacle you know so you it's a
no-brainer that when that role came
along it just seemed absolutely
right that i would be doing it you know
it was never any argument in my in my
head at all
right what do you enjoy the most about
these types of roles
well i enjoy the ambiguity of them i
enjoy
the hidden elements the mysterious
elements it's all the obvious stuff the
obvious stuff is so obvious but it's
where it comes from you know it's it's
the
it's the uh residue of where you you you
know the reservoir rather there's no
residue the reservoir where it all comes
from this
kind of dynamic
demonic you know because they are
demonic figures
uh all all men of ambition are that's
what they're driven by
and there's no question that you're
seeing
logan is one of the most ambitious
persons ever because he's also it's all
him
uh he doesn't he's not ready to divest
his kingdom
but he's ready to find
a successor
and the successor is not arriving
it's not coming and he's
he's given his family every benefit of
every doubt
and they've come up short you know
they're consistently
deep disappointment to him but he just
goes on because they are his kids and he
loves them and he hopes that one day
a light will go on and suddenly ah there
they are the childhood who's going to
inherit it all but at the moment
it's looking less and less likely i love
that you said he loves he loves them and
i know that you know as the character
you you are the character and you can't
judge it but i think some people
watching would think does logan love his
children it was the first question
i asked jesse armstrong when i started
season one
because i thought
does he love his children
and jesse said he loves his children
very much
he just doesn't express it in that way
he doesn't cuddle them he's never done
that he's incapable of doing that partly
because of we don't know yet but partly
possibly
because of his own background possibly
because of the way he was brought up i
mean we know
from episode four i think it is in the
first season when he goes for a swim and
we see his back covering these
uh he's been beaten so in a way he has
been abused physically
so
he does feel
a deep love for his children but at the
same time
they are
they continue to disappoint
they continue not to live up to his
expectations of what they could be
and um
and they're entitled and they're spoilt
and there's nothing and also he knows
there's nothing can be done about that
because just that's just the way things
are you know when you have that amount
of wealth
you know you're not going to deprive
your children and you'll maybe send them
to military school or do all kinds of
disciplinary things but even then i
don't think logan is that sort he
allowed people to be who they were and
sometimes
they come up short you know they really
do i mean lo kendall does
roman certainly does and sadly um
um
chiv who's probably his favorite child
just she just cannot keep her mouth shut
and she talks at the wrong moments it's
just
it's very galling
and he has to deal with it
yeah you mentioned you know logan's
backstory and it's probably because of
stuff that he's been through i actually
wanted to ask you that do you think he
had a favorite child growing up but i
know you just mentioned shiv
i think chef i think you should point
his favorite child because he's his
daughter you know we all love our
daughters i have three sons and a
daughter and my daughter of course
has always got the special place you
know that's that's the old
father-daughter relationship that you
you can't get around that that's why for
leah it's doubly difficult because he's
got three daughters so he so he's he's
he's he's
cut into three ways right
but uh now shiv is
definitely the one that he sees you know
she's she's a sweetheart and she's his
little girl
but she's also
proven
certain things uh you know she's there's
this is
a kind of level of immaturity to her
which she cannot understand why she is
the way she is
and
and avarice it's the avariciousness of
all the children which he finds a little
daunting
another thing i always wondered that i
wanted to ask you is you know when
sometimes when i'm around a certain
person and they say something a lot i i
will just subconsciously pick up on that
um and i was wondering
when you dip into logan and you get out
of him do you somehow in your own life
use the f word more oh god don't i mean
it's it's the biggest plague i've had is
the fact that i'm
my swearing has gone up by
at least
60 percent
you know you know i mean i i never i
mean i i swore i mean i'm not somebody
who didn't swear i used to swear but now
i swear such a lot and that's the
infectiousness of logan i mean he's
he's made me kind of
you know i've my language is somewhat
deteriorated
or it's gotten better it depends who you
ask
in the end which of the roy children do
you think gets the big job as brian
it's hard to say
it really is hard to say
and it would be wrong of me to speculate
uh which one has
uh
the one who will get that
the one who will get
the
reward is the one who deserves it and we
have to see who that's going to be
this life is not for everyone
it's a number on a piece of paper
it's a fight for a knife in the mud
i'm a good guy
i'm better than you
i'll beast them
we'll go full
beast
[Music]